[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
federal court is back in session for the
q's sarah lawrence college sex cult
leader this was the night that she said
larry put a bag over her head and
essentially
threatened to waterboard her plus a
murder spree just minutes from disney
world did a one-time physical therapist
murder his wife children and family dog
and the accused oxford high school
shooter appears in court are you okay
with proceeding via zone
could the 15 year old be headed back to
school but first will convicted killer
scott peterson receive a new trial the
latest developments as his defense
alleges juror misconduct law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin nearly 20 years after the murder
of lacey peterson and her unborn son
connor husband and convicted killer
scott peterson says he deserves a new
trial a series of evidentiary hearings
continued on thursday where a california
judge will soon decide whether peterson
should receive a new trial
it all stems from allegations of german
misconduct based on juror number seven
from peterson's 2004 trial rochelle
niece dubbed strawberry shortcake by the
media indicated she had never been
abused while filling out her juror
questionnaire niece later admitted she
was involved in multiple domestic
disturbance incidents at least one of
which happened when she was pregnant
defense attorneys say that constitutes
german misconduct and that their client
should receive a new trial a series of
evidentiary hearings for the that motion
began in february where niece took the
stand she told the judge she filled out
the jury forms accurately saying she
never considered herself a victim she
also said she never held the murder
against peterson but admitted to writing
to the defendant after his conviction in
2004 peterson was convicted for the 2002
murder of wife lacey and unborn son
connor he was sentenced to death but the
california supreme court later threw out
that ruling he was then re-sentenced to
life in prison peterson has maintained
his innocence
let's see if we can shed some more light
on the question of new trial or not
joining us today is legal analyst kirk
nermey and terry austin kirk is there
any end in sight to this question of
whether or not peterson will get a new
trial and when can we expect a decision
well to answer the last part of your
question first brian i think we can it's
going to take a while i mean we have a
complicated matter here the court is
docket is probably being full with some
of those trials were backed up during
the pandemic is going to have to look at
the transcript the miss niece so what
she said during var dyer during their
original testimony compare that to her
testimony and take a really good deep
dive into the law because this isn't the
kind of decision that can be rendered in
one or two sentences and the judge knows
that whatever his or her decision is
going to be that ultimately is going to
be appealed so he or she is going to
want that ruling to be well reasoned so
while we might get an answer within a
few months as from the trial court the
ultimate answer isn't going to be
decided until the court of appeals
weighs in on this issue i suspect it
seems like more rounds of legal
procedures as we continue terry if
peterson is granted a new trial what are
the next steps
you know what the case is going to go
back to square one literally back to
square one and we'll have pre-trial
hearings pre-trial motions and i
guarantee you one of those motions will
be to let his client out on his own
recognizance because we know that
peterson's been in jail and that will be
the first thing they want to do they'll
be discovery they'll be looking for more
documents they'll be depositions so that
each of the attorneys basically can
impeach the witnesses once again based
on yet more depositions etc so i think
it'll help the defense overall because
they will be able to see what the
prosecution is going to do they've
already seen the case and my humble
advice to the prosecution is leave no
stone unturned because you will need all
the evidence possible yeah and if there
is a new trial we'll probably see an
extensive extensive wader
in terms of not only the questionnaire
but also in questioning of the
perspective perspective jurors thank you
both
switching now to news out of the
caribbean where the private islands of
the disgraced financer jeffrey epstein
are for sale with a 125 million dollar
asking price attorneys for epstein's
estate say the money from the sale will
go towards several outstanding legal
cases including a civil racketeering
lawsuit in 2020 the attorney general of
the u.s virgin islands filed a suit
against epstein's estate and attorneys
the complaint states in part quote
epstein threw an associate with
defendants trafficked raped sexually
assaulted and held captive underage
girls and young women at his properties
in the virgin islands right now
epstein's attorneys and the u.s virgin
islands government are in talks for a
settlement in 2019 epstein died by
suicide in a jail cell as he faced
numerous charges of sex trafficking and
in december of last year epstein's
longtime companion kelaine maxwell was
found guilty of sex trafficking in
relation to her time with epstein
and in celebrity news former child star
amanda vines is released from a court
conservatorship after nearly nine years
on tuesday a judge ruled the 35 year old
is competent to manage her own affairs
from finances to medical treatment this
comes just months after pop star britney
spears was released from her highly
publicized conservatorship while spears
received pushback as she attempted to
end the conservatorship vine's parents
agreed with the decision to end hers
vines had originally been placed under
the conservatorship at age 27 after
multiple arrests and drug and alcohol
abuse that's when her parents voiced
concerned that she may hurt herself or
others unless they were given control of
her finances and medical care vines now
maintains she is sober she first rose to
fame as a child star on the tv channel
nickelodeon where she starred in such
shows as the amanda show
still ahead on law and crime daily just
miles from disney world prosecutors say
a man murdered his wife three children
and family dog but first the accused
michigan high school shooter appears in
court how he could be headed back to
school from behind bars
[Music]
welcome back the accused oxford high
school shooter appears in court
virtually on wednesday where a michigan
judge rules he will remain in the
oakland county jail for adults because
suspect ethan crumbly is only 15 years
old monthly check-in hearings will be
held to re-evaluate whether he should be
moved to the children's village crumbly
is charged with multiple counts of
first-degree murder assault with a
deadly weapon and terrorism stemming
from a november 2021 shooting spree at
oxford high school four students were
killed and others injured crumbly's
parents jennifer and james crumbly are
also charged in connection to the
shooting with involuntary manslaughter
officials say crumbly's parents ignored
warning signs of the shooting such as
disturbing drawings and calls to see a
therapist on thursday ethan crumbly
appeared virtually in court where his
guardian and lightham discussed a plan
for his future schooling
to implement uh either the high school
equivalency program
or
a ged
and additionally that would once he has
achieved either the high school
equivalency diploma or the ged he then
would be able to continue in that
program to be able to um do some
community college courses
um miss george indicated that she has uh
talked with captain vita about being
able to provide him uh his own laptop to
be able to have
you know a certain block of time um
every day for him to be able to uh work
uh on that uh program i did speak with
him yesterday he is thinking about what
path he wants to uh proceed with but the
earliest that we can start implementing
that would uh have to be after his 16th
birthday which is in approximately
another month
all right before we've talked about the
school of terry austin so who better to
break down the latest crumbly hearing
than our own co-host terry austin and
legal analyst kirk nermey terry what are
your thoughts on the educational
components of crumbly's pre-trial
detention
you know prison education is not a
guaranteed right under the constitution
it certainly is not an enumerated right
but it is considered something that most
prisoners do get particularly if you are
in primary education if you are not an
adult and i think that here we see that
they're arguing to give him education
because he is not an adult and i think
he probably should get that education
depending on how long he's going to be
in prison and we know if he's you know
going to be in prison for quite some
time these are horrible crimes that he's
committed so i think that uh they are
making the right arguments and i think
that he probably should get an education
while he is in prison yeah now kirk i
understand if michigan law but i'm still
kind of asking the question why monthly
check-ins and what is the court
expecting could change from now to the
next court date that would make a
juvenile jail more appropriate here
ultimately brian i don't think there's
anything that could happen in this case
that could alter the course of mr
crumbly's confinement you know you're
right that there's statutory required
that review every 30 days but given the
horrific nature of this crime i don't
see the court ever changing his his pre
pre-trial uh in
incarceration and think about it this
way brian too he's beginning to
seek out fame he's got this these ideas
of his fan mail seeking out his fan mail
and his harry potter book you put him in
an environment with other juveniles and
he could become a bit of a folk hero
because of this fame because of the
money he has in his commissary account
and all those things combined i could
not see a judge in judge rowe in this
case
changing
the conditions of his confinement at all
i think he will remain spent his life in
the
adult prison yeah and don't get me wrong
i'm not saying get rid of these
check-ins i'm saying maybe three to six
months but why month after month after
month it just doesn't seem to make sense
to me but we'll keep track of these
hearings and others in the ethan crumbly
case coming up on law and crime daily
how the health of accused sarah lawrence
cult leader lawrence ray is affecting
his federal trial plus a grisly murder
scene in the shadow of disneyland why
prosecutors hope to block the insanity
defense for the man accused of murdering
his wife young children and family dog
welcome back to law and crime daily
prosecutors in florida try to block the
insanity defense for a man accused of
murdering his wife three children and
family dog just miles from disney world
in december 2019. anthony todd has pled
not guilty to four counts of first
degree murder and one count of animal
cruelty tot was taken into custody in
january 2020 after investigators
discovered the dead bodies of his family
members and dog inside a celebration
florida home at the time officers were
attempting to arrest todd a physical
therapist on health care fraud charges
investigators believe the top families
bodies were inside the home for weeks
before they were found autopsy results
found they died of stab wounds and
lethal amounts of benadryl while todd
initially confessed to the murders he
later blamed his wife megan for the
deaths prosecutors are now trying to
prevent todd from using an insanity
defense filing a motion that would limit
the evidence presented by the defense
about tot's mental health status as of
now no filings about the insanity
defense have been made after multiple
delays todd's case is expected to go to
trial on april 4. law and crime network
will be in the courtroom to bring you
gavel to gavel coverage
legal analyst kirk nermey and terry
austin are back as we look ahead to the
law on crime's upcoming trial coverage
terry do you think the prosecution will
be able to block the defense from
asserting an insanity defense
you know i don't think he's going to
prevail on that motion listen based on
this indictment and based on the crime
itself clearly that is a legitimate
defense whether or not it prevails we
will see under florida law they can
claim insanity but they're obviously
going to have to prove there's a mental
illness and because of that mental
illness they didn't know what they were
doing or they didn't understand that it
was wrong and so it's a burden it's got
to be clear and convincing and it's the
burden that the defense is going to have
to carry so i think the judge is going
to actually deny that motion allow the
defense and leave it to the jury to
determine whether or not there is
insanity in this case before doing or
after the commission of the crime yeah
kirk the defense usually doesn't have to
prove anything but but terry is touching
on a great point here it seems like some
or a lot of heavy lifting uh because
supposedly there's a false confession
and now a potential insanity defense
what does the defense have to prove or
show to make these arguments work
well you know it's not a matter of
necessarily proving anything except of
course with the insanity defense it has
to be proved but a confession is
obviously one of some of the most
damning evidence of defending in faith
but it doesn't have to be faced alone if
you will when we talk about the issues
the evidence that are advanced in
insanity defense and how that might
affect someone's ability to confess so
what what the defense will be trying to
do is demonstrate that that
confession obtained isn't as credible as
it might otherwise be so you put a false
confession expert up on the stand to
talk about to raise doubt to raise that
reasonable doubt regarding the veracity
of the confession along with all the
other evidence to show that he really
didn't properly confess but that's what
this the defense is going to be trying
to do here to cast doubt on everything
the state is advancing forward because
of his mental state yeah as i said again
make sure to check the long crime
network for gavel to gavel coverage on
that trial and ohio testimony wrapped up
for the week on thursday in the case of
accused killer william hussell the
former icu physician is on trial for
allegedly killing patients with
excessive amounts of fentanyl the 14
deaths he's charged with happened
between 2015 and 2018. who sells defense
team argues the former doctor was giving
end-of-life comfort care to the patients
he was treating whoso faces 15 years to
life on each count if convicted over the
last five weeks the state's case has
focused on the amounts of medicine whose
cell ordered nursing staff to administer
to patients jurors have heard from
husel's former co-workers at mount
carmel hospital and from family members
of the several of the alleged victims
thursday's testimony included the
daughter of melissa pennix the woman
whose death reportedly sparked the
initial investigation into whoso
i said
if
there's no hope why were you
there's nothing you can do if there's no
hope why was something being put in our
arm when we walked in
and he said oh we never stop trying
what happened after uh the discussion
about
withdrawing care
well we talked about it as a family and
considering that we aren't none of us
are medical experts and if a doctor
tells you
that your loved one's brain dead
i have no idea whatsoever why you would
doubt them because they're the educated
one so we
accepted that
and as a family we decided to have the
event removed
when we come back the sarah lawrence
college sex cult trial alleged cult
member claudia jury is back on the stand
for the third time our adam classville
is at the courthouse with the latest
developments
[Music]
welcome back intense testimony on direct
examination of a key witness finishes up
in the case of accused sarah lauren's
sex cult leader lawrence ray at a new
york federal courthouse this comes after
the trial was put on hold for a day when
the defendant was rolled out of court on
a stretcher and taken to the hospital
ray faces several federal charges
including racketeering sex trafficking
and money laundering all stemming from
alleged abuse and the extortion of his
daughter's college friends for over the
last decade one of his alleged victims
claudio jury began her testimony on
friday telling jurors rey gained control
over her through threats and violence
she shared testimony of him allegedly
hurting her and threatening to hurt
people she knew even her family jury
testified she turned to sex work to pay
rey back after he had convinced her she
had tried to poison him and that she had
damaged his new york apartment moments
after jury's testimony tuesday
about rey allegedly urging her to take
steps to make herself more desirable to
men he was taken from the courthouse and
driven to the hospital by an ambulance
court resumed on thursday in law and
crime's adam classfeld was back in the
courtroom as jury's testimony continued
with details from the quote knight of
torture back in 2018.
when opening statements kicked off the
prosecutor had said
about an incident that she described as
a long night of torture claudia drury
said that essentially in late
2018
she was at the gregory hotel
in midtown manhattan when larry ray
entered with his accused co-conspirator
isabella pollack this was the night
that she said larry put a bag over her
head started to suffocate her ordered
her to strip down
and
took her in her restrained state to an
air conditioner and poured water over
her head it was horrifying testimony
she says that she learned after
this
night of torture that she describes that
she said lasted between seven and eight
hours
that it was being recorded by larry's
accused co-conspirator we heard an audio
recording of that in court and i have to
tell you when
that was being played
you could see the witness tilting her
head back putting her head forward it
was clearly a painful recording for her
to listen to so this was very dramatic
testimony very emotional testimony to
kick off the end of her direct
examination
this is this is purely speculation i'm
not saying that these trips to the
hospital aren't real but we've heard
testimony of rey's history of
manipulation now we're seeing health
related delays when the star witness is
testifying then he's fine a day or two
afterwards
is that a little suspicious to you
a little suspicious to me is as the same
as you but i bet most importantly to his
case
the jury is probably pretty suspicious
of this think about all the things
they've heard that he's capable of in
terms of manipulating these women women
what have you and now we're talking
about you know when testimony against
him is presented he's suddenly sick and
then he's coming back yeah this is not a
good look you're only going to upset the
jurors and i'm sure they're thinking the
same thing that we are both thinking
brian again just speculation i'm not his
doctor i don't know but
seems a little
odd to me is what i'm saying terry it
seemed like the defendant recorded most
of the acts involving his alleged
victims why do you think he he would
create incriminating evidence that could
be used against him later
you know if i were the prosecutor i
would argue that the reason he took
those tapes is one he was displaying
that horrific behavior but he wanted to
go back and further humiliate his
victims and so he taped all of this and
i think that's an added level of
horribleness to this crime and i think
he also derived or at least if i were
the prosecution i would argue that he
derives some sort of pleasure and not
just doing the act but actually taping
the act and it's really great for the
prosecution usually in these types of
cases it's he said she said now that
they have these tapes there's no
question they have very clear evidence
on what was going on and i think they'll
be able to prove this case beyond a
reasonable doubt to this jury seeing
these tapes yeah the tapes are really
damaging and of course it gives a
greater insight to this mindset of
lawrence ray kirk terry thank you as
always and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you